hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three awesome games I've
got some weird ones here not too bizarre
thankfully not bizarre enough to be a
three bizarre games but should be pretty
fun so let's check them out
okay well whoa welcome to how to be a
tree you are a tree
don't worry being a tree is easy alright
how to be a tree do nothing
tree life sure is nice huh sometimes I
envy you trees what are you a floating
eyeball I hope you don't mind me staying
here I'm just taking in your majesty on
this fine day
I mean that's pretty much what everybody
does to me they just take in my majesty
oh god this isn't even I'm offline well
good thing that doesn't matter oh that's
not even fullscreen how do I make it
fullscreen
well whatever alright I guess I just got
to do this I don't know what this guy's
talking about he's jabbering on about
something oh I don't know what oh god
okay what happened
I don't understand alright the devotee
oh oh you are a tree Oh God oh hey what
are you doing oh oh my tree just press R
and let's forget this ever happened
no I'm a tree [ __ ] you get out of my
way I'm a [ __ ] tree okay alright
oh my god how are you doing this you
know I'm not a hundred percent sure so I
think this is the mist of whoa
yeah the mystery is just up in the air
hi and so you disregarded the eyes
imposed ideals and bounced into a
curious portal press R or I'll tell on
you ah alright sure it's a little trippy
a little trippy little little trippy
alright oh god no oh God
yeah parently we good God the truth
is it alright sure we're gonna go with a
whole lot of sure look I don't know
exactly how to do locomotion here so
just bear with me okay this is not
obviously not correct no that's not
correct either
wait okay so up does that right turns me
that way which goes forward somehow
compress and crawl oh oh okay
Wow Wow here I go whee oh boy this is
this is messed up man straighten and
then shrink and quickly expand okay
straighten okay straighten or run free
and embrace chaos okay oh that works hey
that's great
wait I see good god the music is so
grating this is just hey you got the
triangle of power buddy
thank you okay here we go here we are
this is a messed up game seek your
ancestors child I am so confused I think
it was just the most confused I've ever
been in my life okay the open world oh
wow venture forth and return to fractal
space with 13 of your brethren all right
but do not forget yourself on your
journey
remember you are a fractal all right
after all you cannot be a tree can you
you do not even have roots okay whatever
you say buddy wow I don't know what this
is but it doesn't seem to be deadly
seems like the the Giants - oh [ __ ]
little worm things Pleasant that's not
pleasant at all okay
all right so I somehow got a straighten
out there we go okay we're just go
wiggle worm
oh no okay hang on we're gonna wiggle
worm our way into this little thing no
god damn it no no no no no no no not the
hole okay dive headfirst yeah yeah yeah
there we go
I don't know where this is going but I
got a bad feeling about oh [ __ ]
oh okay well I'm dead alright well that
was that was horrible okay in the hole
in the hole straighten out there we go
slide that's that's weird okay I got up
no no my roots I mean I didn't even get
my fractal friends I guess that's
control roots I don't control my roots
would you mind moving your roots oh is
that a worm oh my god I hate that thank
you
you're what all right
god I'm gaudy oh this is horrible
horrible horrible horrible horrible
horrible horrible everything's horrible
horrible horrible I'm through I guess I
didn't want to go through but I'm
through horrible mark you want up all
right oh I don't get up apparently okay
Wow all right this the worst thing I've
ever seen in my life there we go we're
free all right get out of my face shut
up you're not a tree I'm a tree okay I
gotta get in this hole but not going the
exit to get
stupid thing okay yeah I wanted to dive
who would have been great if I didn't
like a somersault dive into the hole but
I didn't so I know why would you do that
you control like a piece of spaghetti
this is much more difficult than it
seems it doesn't exactly control the way
you'd expect a limp noodle to control
oddly enough you'd think it would but it
don't there we go this is gonna get in
there there we go all right I did I get
it
I got it okay I got it all right
whatever okay so I need to expand
rapidly nope
I did it okay checkpoint apparently so
guys awaits laps around it so horrible
it's so horrible I got it with my roots
I can't penetrate that there we go now
let's no let's just get in the hole
great not no god damn you oh [ __ ] job
geez ohms I'm going right
it's like [ __ ] Bennett 40 I'm not
gonna be able to get out of this well
there I'm dead okay great oh I'm alive
great there we go I'm in Oh off off okay
I shouldn't be here but here I am
apparently ah yeah I can't move forward
that would be okay well take some of my
off well there was no point in going in
there was there I don't know man
okay roots yeah Wow yeah ow oh there was
a point in going oh I got it anyway
whatever cuz it doesn't matter there we
go there we go I'm embracing chaos chaos
no that's wait no but I didn't get
everything oh I probably got to go
through the little wet it's fine fine
didn't need those anyway straighten out
there we go
okay Oh No hahaha I am the best okay and
then flat as can be do not saw me in
three there it is
I need that no I need that no I need
that
there we go I got it okay good can I go
to this thing now can I get out please
just let me out just let me out
No let me out please
there we go oh god this is just the
weirdest game I've ever played well
maybe not the weirdest but this is just
bizarre this makes it in the land of
saws oh boy I can't wait to go to the
land of saws hey grandpappy why will you
take me to Saul and I always done wanted
to go very real there we go yeah I got
it okay I just need to jump up embrace
chaos chaos control no no no
there we go got it ow [ __ ] well didn't
get a checkpoint so I guess dumb oh wait
I already got those nevermind I guess I
did get a checkpoint ow
alright just go go man no go forward
come good no don't do it you know my
this game sucks
this game just lay flat Oh Rick okay
just lay flat flat
alright now lay flat perfect don't move
a muscle
I don't even know if you have muscles
frankly I hope you don't embrace chaos
ow
chaos control can't checkpoint alright
now go up no no no god damn it okay
embrace chaos control this is a terrible
checkpoint why would anybody want this
checkpoint kalman him
oh wait I got it embrace chaos
I guess Oh No
okay flatten there we go flatten perfect
perfect we dunzo baby and so you fell
into the factory in shoot and we're
transform what huh I'm a book now that's
the endgame I guess you're a book now
what oh oh okay we I'm embracing kale so
no I don't get it but I did it guys yeah
there are different paths I get that
which is what I'm doing I need to fix
this I'll freeze you until we can get
you right no no no don't worry about
freezing me no no no freeze ray engaged
okay whatever
miss me hey whoa hey whoa Oh God and so
goes the life of a tree ah captured Oh
all right I guess I can't expand oh I
don't want to keep playing this I don't
want to keep going on this one I think
I'm good I think I think the life of a
tree has been properly explored and my
eyes are probably scarred so I think I'm
good okay that one was a success a
rousing success we're gonna dig deep
okay this is a game about my favorite
part of something it's like my my
favorite home beach body trainer Sean T
always tells me get my knees up keep my
core tight and dig deep that's what he
says that's like his three things Sean T
always tells me get my knees up above
the waist well I keep my core tight no
matter what I do and dig deep those are
the those are the three things that
always have to be done Wow very
impressive oh okay all right right Wow
oh wow
this is literally my favorite part of
minecraft was just digging holes in the
ground I'm glad that they found a game
that really does tie in to just that
aspect of the game this is a hospital
ah no don't this is okay there's this is
pretty cool I'm down with this oh [ __ ]
you're dead all right well sorry about
that
cool
all right I'm down for this press fast
but I want to what are we gonna press
fast oh that's dumb
okay oh hey buddy how you doing uh okay
no that's that's pretty intuitive I
thought it was gonna be like a press to
sprint kind of thing that's not too bad
I got I do got a spam it but it's okay
ah oh [ __ ] oh hey no don't follow me get
blown oh [ __ ] oh he's dead
not sad okay is that invulnerability or
something probably oh [ __ ] oh okay thank
you
this is not bad it's interesting it's a
different concept than what I'm used to
but not bad wow wow wow wow it's quite
satisfying I gotta admit this would
probably be a good mobile game you know
what I mean what did I just do exploded
you're ready for adventure Oh am i I
thought I was currently in Advent oh
here we go I guess we're going now okay
I thought that was just a tutorial stuff
baby stuff this is this is top tier
gameplay right here oh no my body how am
I expecting to get out of this hole that
just goes down into in definite forever
because that seems to be a problem for
this okay oh wait I got something here
what do I have dig deep reward claim oh
it is a mobile game this is available on
it I didn't think it was a mobile game
okay it's a bit of a mobile game but not
bad okay I mean it's fun I got no
problem with it so long it's not just a
money-grubbing mobile game then
we got no problems ah no ah that was a
bad move all right well I can't say that
I'm good at this game yet well I can't
say that I'm ever gonna get good at this
game good thing I got this new keyboard
with mechanical switches even though I
hate mechanical keyboards but I did get
it why cuz I'm an idiot boom kaboom wait
no I thought that was gonna go a bit
farther than it did
okay swoosh you know I don't like a
mechanical keyboard it's as I needed two
keyboards and one of them's wireless and
one of them's not no well that's hardly
fair okay what is this disposable boost
I don't know he's sure yeah okay all
right you have one okay I don't know
what that means but I'm gonna keep going
collect ten mega gold pieces fall on an
alien and crush it
why are aliens under the ground am I the
only one that's confused by that I just
don't see how they got under the ground
I guess it's kind of like how the story
behind those Gears of War like isn't
that the story behind Gears of War like
that it's kind of underground aliens are
the aliens I don't know I've never
actually played the games I was played
Gears of War in college with one of the
people who lived in my my dorm hall he
would invite me over to play I forget
his name but he invited me over to play
but we would only ever play like
multiplayer competitive matches because
that's all he wanted to do and I didn't
know how to play the game so I was like
dude can you explain to me at least like
what I'm doing a like I'm just dying a
bunch to you who's the only other person
playing this game and like he just would
not yeah he just wouldn't explain how
the game was played so we just kill me
over and over and over again and he'd
kill me in the most annoying ways
possible because he would like he'd
shoot me I get knocked down and there's
like a point where you can get back up
and he would just stand over me with
like a shotgun or something wait for me
to get back up and in the meantime I
can't do anything he would wait for me
to get back up and then kill me
straight up like and he was just shoot
me right in the head my head would blow
up I'd be dead horribly dead and then
just that was it and that was all we did
and that lasted for about 30 minutes and
I was like dude this is not fun
for me Lou whatever man larry's whatever
and just I just remember that so
distinctly as being the douchiest way
someone could ever invite you to play a
game just kill you and I'm sure that
everybody has some kind of experience
with something like oh no I forgot about
Myka boomer no he wasn't even my friend
no he was not my friend he was just
someone who lived in the same dorm hall
and I was bored and I was just like yeah
sure we'll uh we'll play yeah I've never
played by I saw the trailer for that
game looks cool you know I thought that
maybe had a co-op campaign or something
this is like nope he just wanted to kill
me a lot over and over again just said
use space what was it supposed to be I
can't use space anymore I guess it's not
a thing maybe it's the thing only the
beginning let me blow up again real
quick
and I'ma blow up or die because I want
to use this disposable boosts unit
whatever that is go for it
use it boost there oh that's nice oh
that's real nice oh that's nice I don't
know what the benefit of gold versus
mega gold is those are worth one apiece
Oh
fifty oh that's totally worth it that's
way better it's it beep more it'd be
better to go after those versus anything
in this game okay all right well you
live and learn
davi oh oh I can still get it okay I
miss that but whatever okay I think I
get the gist of this game I'm not really
too interested in playing this to
completion but let's just see how far I
go with this one run of it and deal from
there okay now this is a trick but I'm
not chased by aliens so it's not that
big of it no no no no okay
it's not that big of a trick I mean this
is the kind of game that's like it's
kind of perfect mobile game because it's
just it's just a little bit ridiculous
concept but just repetitive enough
gameplay that's slightly addictive it's
not bad I got no complaints about this
game but it's not exactly the kind of
game that really sparks my interest hey
that's nice oh wow
hey bonus just because I usually like
either a story if I'm wasting my time or
at least the feeling of a story
something like that
but right now this one's a loo [ __ ] no
no how was I supposed to be able to get
out of that one I guess I could have
blown up or whatever all right so I
think we get that game that's pretty
good we could have been playing together
in Gears of War so that guy was just a
dick and he's wanting to blow my head
off all right so this one's called
project blockchains II and I don't know
if this is like some future where
cryptocurrency took over the world and
they just absolutely destroyed
everything and it just created zombie
virus for blockchain stuff if that's
even possible
oh oh yeah oh that music though oh
that's nice let's just go for it I get
random challenge soldier rookie Ranger
other soldier that what you were saying
right now the horde of zombies are
coming as the captain you must keep the
bunker in safe yeah that's not a good
start find out the survivors across the
city destroy the zombies and fight the
Raiders resist until the reef or sment
reinforcements arrive all right then
project blockchains ii is a third-person
shooter game with RPG and tactical view
mechanics get ready to defend the bunker
whoa what happened j2c controls next to
consume you blue elements or buttons you
can interact with I'm a button okay was
to move mouse wheel to zoom in and out
left mouse button move them across with
the right what whoa what the hell oh
this is battle oh okay wow this is not
gonna I'm not gonna remember all these
but okay the orders are for all your
troops why to send quick orders build
things with the Z key why this okay
that's a lot to take in
okay siren sure they're right hello hi
buds hey come on over here did I press
the right button
okay formation line find cover
/ I don't think that was cover
I've already four low bullet time okay Z
build a barricade this is kind of cool I
mean if it actually works out I don't
know if it's gonna work out but if it
does that's cool alright explosive
barrel one there one there ammo box
I'm parently all done right there I
guess
and then mine's deployer sure
alright mines there we go oh maybe you
guys should get away from that take oh
you don't take cover then okay
let me go most tactical there we go okay
you go there okay so you yeah just there
we okay all right okay all right that's
good I guess
cool let's let's do it then
well this is inaccurate okay I'm
concerned about that big one I don't
know if I should what's dead never mind
that is handy with the distraction Oh
Go Go guys you don't need to be turned
what your legs a little concerned about
your leg your legs there but are that's
fine ah I can see that this is still
early in development with like the non
finished models no textures all that
stuff they're just trying to get the
gameplay there that's not bad like this
isn't bad it needs some more refinement
with the the gunplay Oh God world map
tutorial I don't know what what the hell
is that the space bead bunker gee I'm
not gonna remember these Manny's bunker
in bunker you can train troops improve
technology bite coins II Oh white coin
that's funny
that's really funny if you see this icon
hover the mouse to get more info Sambi
hatches zombies raider storage raiders
survivors bah
don't let the survivors count reached
zero okay right uh-huh yep
yeppers peppers you got it what do i do
oh [ __ ]
wait no what are you doing who's doing
that I don't know what I'm doing wait
now Jake controls uh hmm okay oops oh
yeah I do
oh yeah I do oh you know where am i I
don't know where I am okay
Oh put that there put that there put
this here put a barricade
here gonna put this there and this there
all right whatever let's just go for it
it wasn't exactly difficult so hopefully
it's not gonna be difficult either hey
you guys want to point in the right
direction maybe I'm not pointing the
right direction is that zombies oh [ __ ]
oh you guys are right okay oh [ __ ]
okay Oh let's go mano-a-mano in this Hey
look I'm breathing you can see my breath
Hey
all right you losers you nerds what are
the weapons we got here pistol well
though the pistol is better than the
machine gun was oh sweet what about
shoddy Brad I love it brains really
really these guys are brains hungry for
brains you guys want some brains tea
posing over there this is surprisingly
well-made for a free game and just to
demo at that it's the present really
they spawn out a huge okay they respond
they spot out of huge tombstones perfect
but you see little lesson about game
development see now that they've got
like the gameplay and everything is
placeholder all they have to do is just
start refining the gameplay down and
then replace everything with not
placeholder stuff slowly start to flesh
it out and then that's it you can
actually work out pretty well because a
lot of games they try to make it look
good first and that's like a big mistake
looking good is not important in the
beginning phases of making a game it
just needs to play well like that is
only the thing that you need let's go
fight some Raiders maybe can only go
fast fast like super fast can you go
here why aren't you going there all
right never mind I guess we can't fight
the Raiders yeah let's go you know I'm
not even gonna we're just gonna go for
it yeah but no it's really cool like I
mean the city looks terrible with all
its pure white aspects of it it's not
even stylized like superhot but you know
it's it's just nice hey are you going
peek-a-ball peek-a-ball peek-a-ball
where's these big old tombstones there
they is man I don't even need to do
anything my guys just kill them all
anyway
jeez there is a bit too much like recoil
when I shoot it's just too jarring
when the camera shakes like stuff up
it's like I'm gonna punch to the neck
hey hey
guys why won't you watch my back there
we go easy peasy
hey survive ease I don't know if there's
a good thing to go for here but I'm
gonna go there doesn't seem to want to
let me go to the Raiders camps huh what
a group of enemies are attacking me okay
all right let's go for it where are they
attacking from wonder if these guys are
actually gonna be any tougher because
like in any zombie game the real threat
is other people not the zombies
themselves all right three two one
contact
Wow Jesus how much you just kill him
okay let me get my shotgun I just want
to pop out from corners and just blast
people cuz otherwise I'm gonna die no
okay never mind
they are bull let's move fast apparently
oh but bullets move slow if I do this
smart I'm smart yeah [ __ ] wait maybe not
that smart I'm gonna die I don't know
how to oh there we go
healing who knew it could be that easy
Oh like a dream wow wow wow wow wow wow
it's like I'm playing apex legends I'm
gonna be the champion guys I'm gonna be
the best I'm already the best you guys
don't even need to tell me about it
I already know all right just a few more
to mop up let me heal it's like every
like every like six shot or so it'll
splay off into the distance I have no
idea why one more let me do a sweet 360
no-scope on this one you see that it's
pretty good right no right we Casey died
I'm so sad about that apparently alright
I guess we gotta get home I think let's
we can go here oh that's fine I'll kill
all units to win the battle easy I wish
there was something our I hope there's
something that's like a persistent base
that you got to build up back home
because that would be cool like oh do
you want to enter blockchains these
stores yeah yeah I do yeah Wow all right
I only have two people left with me I
don't know how good this is gonna go for
me but sure yeah okay let's do this
probably not the best idea is just to
run out into the open
oh Jesus can't jump over this can I jump
on this can I please just jump on this I
just oh my god there we go
I jumped
yeah take some of that one of these some
of this this is working out real good
for me one down tango Down
alright moving up for better cover never
mind about one of these hoop B all right
let me get closer for AB Kobe Kobe oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna die I'm gonna die he'll
he'll damn it nice like it weren't no
think it's like someone using a full
heal in in uh in Pokemon this is really
cheap and cheesy and just makes you feel
real [ __ ] but it's me doing it so I feel
great I don't know what that guy was
shooting at but that was dumb anyway I
got the level 4 I lost TJ not TJ no not
oh [ __ ] oh well hmm that that don't seem
good that don't seem good I should
probably be home well that ain't good um
go to battle alright this is yeah this
is what I was open for ok why don't I
have more people with me I felt like I
had more people before all right
whatever let's go for it whoa I got more
people where did y'all come from okay
alright then thank you thank you for it
here follow me wait wait [ __ ] do they
follow me or
select all platoons uh here follow no
just huge dark just just you okay Oh
what are you shooting at that building
piss you off
you'll get up eventually if you shoot
keep shooting enough you'll get through
the building and eventually you'll hit
your target so just keep keep keep at it
oh that's a lot but I got grenades
watch this call me LeBron Wow
Wow you guys suck wow you guys suck
Wow you guys suck oh you're terrible
Oh y'all suck no no no no I don't even
need this site down all you suck on the
best alright
so it's a little on a like casualties
how did they die
what what do they just fall over
themselves well it's not fair
alright whatever yes not exactly perfect
right now blood this is a lot of
potential I could see this being a
really cool game the game design aspect
of it like the the idea behind it I
really like Griffin amis trying to flee
I failed to flee
okay well I guess let's just see what
happens when I die bastards come on
see look I got a bajillion people over
there
all right well that was fun but anyway
that it's pretty good I got it I can't
live that is not bad that is kind of fun
if they had some more refinement to it
like the gunplay was a little better Lee
the actual building was more important
like the zombies were a bit smarter in
the AI there's a lot of room here to
grow so project blockchain Z is what
it's called not bad not bad at all so
that was three awesome games thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this game for yourself I'll
provide a link in the description and if
you've got other cool short indie games
that you want me to play put them down
in the comments and check out the huge
playlist of awesome games that I've made
link is in the description as well
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
you